i'm gonna go for my one
okay when did you start singing
um well as far back as i can remember
well my mother says
you know certain things like all mothers
do yeah
oh yes he could sing before we could
walk well in my case that's true
when something up tempo would come on
the radio i would start to move
head would be bopping exactly yeah so my
mother said what the hell am i giving
birth to
because she wasn't used to it you know
yeah yeah so that all the way back
wow yeah crazy i didn't start singing
till i was 18.
really no i played football until i was
about 17. oh right
and i was going to what position i was a
left back i'm right footed
left back in the air in the old change
room yeah like no
and then i played for uh luton town i
played for northampton oh and that was
what i wanted to do
and then i got dropped and i was gonna
go to america and play because i got
offered a scholarship to go to
and play over there and i didn't fancy
it didn't like it anymore just
fell out of love with it and then i got
went to a party and it was a karaoke
machine
right and i had a bit of confidence
after a few after a few cherries
and uh jumped on and started singing and
then it all started there really when i
was 18.
well when i started there was an okay as
a carrier when you started we like when
it was gigs and stuff like that was it
just you
and a band and you'd go touring around
england whales
well whales mostly in wales but when i
started off
i learned to play guitar right just
enough chords to get by mm-hmm
and started playing rock and roll in in
these pubs
and working men's clubs wicked but it
was like really great
training ground so then i got with this
group and i said look there's
there's there's working workman's clubs
in south wales
but nobody's ever gone in there with
with a with a band
yeah you know it's always individual
singers yeah um mostly traditional you
know in wales
first night we go in there right
straight away before when they were
setting up the boys were setting up
oh jesus christ rock and roll who the
hell needs that in there
and i said just a minute fellas you know
hang about
no you're all right tommy we love you
you're lovely but not he's
germaine and then when he not looking
great balls of fire you know
wicked when in doubt great balls of fire
what was it like playing elvis's songs
and then obviously
meeting him meeting him and you were
friends right oh yeah yeah well they're
very close
i was singing elvis presley songs in
these clubs
yeah and pubs and i sing them and they
say wow
you know that's as good as elvis presley
i said well i'll tell him that when i
meet him yeah
oh yeah you manifested it elvis presley
you're joking
i said no i gotta i think i will meet
him
so when i met him and he was walking
towards me i could see these fellas
so he's like i'm ready to tell him how
much he's influenced me
and he's walking towards me singing my
song with his hands it was a ballad you
know
with his hands albuquerque
so what was that moment actually like
when you met him earth shattering
really well it was because elvis presley
was the one so meeting elvis presley was
like
the pinnacle yeah you know what i mean
yeah and then jerry lee lewis and rita
franklin you know all those
wow all those guys but elvis of course
was the one
yeah crazy i always watch this
performance
and like this is honest i watch it on
youtube um
is you with stevie wonder yeah on your
show
what was that like i'm a massive fan of
stevie fantastic
because white man is just crazy and he
was young then he said he was well young
then yeah yeah he's just it was like
though it was 1969
he was either 69 or 70 you know around
there
and uh yeah it was only like 29 you know
then
and um he came on it was fantastic yeah
and he says it to this day you know
thank you for
for taking the time because we did a
take you know because
because there was a lot of songs in
there yeah you know i mean it's a medley
of his songs
and with one or two of mine in there
yeah and um
you know he said i'm not i think we can
do that again and i said
we're going to do that again and my
director said no we got it
it's great we're going to move on i said
no we're not yeah you know especially
his
solo spot because he had to go and play
drums and everything on there
yeah you know and i said no we're not
done you know stevie wants to do it
again and he remembered that
amazing yeah would you ever bring your
show back oh the drop of a hat nobody's
asking me oh come on
people out there bring the show back
yeah because they could steal two toms
yeah exactly tom and tom tom and tom
here we go okay so what was your big
break
i would say like i got on onto the music
scene like
five years ago and i did a song with
chase and status
um all goes wrong and i feel like that
was probably the first time
people heard who i was yep
my first album for me was kind of me
finding my voice and
finding my feet and kind of i didn't
know what i was kind of doing did you
write the first
song you wrote it yeah yeah yeah that's
that's a pluses
yeah but i still didn't really know what
i was doing and i feel like
this album every road that i've just
released my second one
is where i've kind of broke through i
feel like
i i found my feet and i found like what
i'm about and i found my sound too
i think the most important thing is
finding a sound yeah yeah yeah i mean
and
it's taken a minute but now like i'm i'm
there with it you're there yeah
yeah what was your big break but it's
not unusual the first one that's the one
that changed my life
yeah from singing in pubs yeah you know
and clubs into being on tv
looking in the paper and going hey you
know
yeah coming down from the north of
england we stood we stayed we stopped in
this
transport calf right and we didn't have
any money me and my band you know
and the sunday paper came out and then
it was like number 10 or something
yeah and i went jesus great so all these
lorry drivers around you know i said
hey see this that's me yeah right i said
i'm telling you because they didn't know
who i was you know gives a little tune
it's not unusual to be loved by anyone
oh it's not unusual
that have fun with anyone ah
when i see you hanging about with anyone
oh it's not unusual
to see me cry i wanted that
legend wow my mom's going to be going
like that did you know from when you
recorded that song you're like
yes this that's gonna that's gonna do it
well i did the demo
it was a demonstration record that my
manager had written it's not unusual
with lazaree two of them wrote it
together
right four sandy shore wow already had a
couple of number one records you see
yeah in 64 then
and um so i did the demo on it i said i
gotta have this song
yeah and my manager said it's a pop song
i said i don't give a [ __ ] what do you
call it it's a hit and he said
oh i can write a million of those he
never did
so i said that is the song so they
played it the sandy show because they
had to they were commissioned
yeah and um she said whoever's singing
this song that's his song
i couldn't sing this like this wow so i
said god bless you and then boom we went
in the studio we tried it once
like a mild thing with
but then pick it up and then brass you
know
you know just with the bass drum but i
was lucky you know see because it's not
unusual it was global
yeah it went global so yeah
what a tune yeah simple little song but
it was but that's the
way the best tunes are yeah what do you
sing when you're in the shower
ah it all depends what kind of mood i'm
in
all right i know how much soap do i have
you know it all depends how long i got
but
you think that you know elvis pres elvis
presley
right if i was going to do one night
with you all right
one night
here's what i'm now praying for
of things that we too could plan
would make my dreams come true
i want your sweet helping hand
my love's too strong too high
i like that noise
always living my very quiet life
i ain't never done no wrong
now i know that life without you
would be too lonely too long
one night
that's what i've been doing wow that was
amazing what about you
i got some new shoes on and suddenly
everything's right uh-huh
hey i got some new shoes on and
everybody's smiling this
all right and all short little money for
a long long time
surely shining in the sweet sunshine
and i'm running late but i don't need an
excuse
so wearing my brand new shoes
yeah yeah that awesome it's great son
who has had the biggest influence on
your career well there's there's a lot
of people
i listened to a lot of singers when i
was young yeah i still listen to them
now
yeah you know but uh when when you hear
somebody
like frankie lane yeah used to be a big
singer
in the 50s and he had a big voice you
know and he did a lot of
western tunes for movies yeah when i
first heard
amy winehouse right for me that's like
when i first said
meet you downstairs in the bar
her rolled up jeans
and your school t-shirt she said why do
you do with him today
i love that change so much have you
recorded it i have not recorded it you
should do it yeah i would love to
it was great yeah i would love to but um
i feel like when i
that's when i've when i first heard her
voice i was like
oh my god this is what a voice can do to
your soul exactly
and and it's so refreshing i think it's
so refreshing you know because there's
so much electronic
stuff around now and the pitch thing you
know that
yeah you know put you in tune yeah
melody
i actually when i when i'm in the studio
and someone puts a tune on my voice i'm
like
please take that off take it off because
it's [ __ ] awful well
that's good because it's condensed yeah
it condenses everything it takes the
life out of it man
thank you i mean that's what i think it
does but they say oh you're
old-fashioned don't pass it
you know what i mean i said no it's not
i want to hear the voice
for sure i want to hear what that person
is saying yeah
what's been like your favorite kind of
show that you've ever done
where you've come where you've stepped
out and gone you know this
is mad crazy i mean well it's been a
fever though
well there obviously have been a few
bucks yeah yeah well the first time the
one that made me twitch
yeah that yeah was a royal command
performance
in front of the queen oh wow on the
london palladium
live oh wow you know and i was i was
only in the business a couple of years
yeah and then i was you know going on
the stage on live television
and the queen is up in the box amazing
i'm thinking i'd better straighten up
here now
you know i got to be on this yeah have
you ever sung in front of the queen not
yet
it's great she's she's lovely is she
lovely yeah yeah but i'm you know i'm
knighted you see so
what was that like fantastic
unbelievable really yeah i don't think
i've ever experienced anything before
or since like that feeling and you look
into her
and she she's a beautiful woman and she
lights up i mean i've met her many
times yeah but when she's doing that you
know yeah it's serious
yeah that's it crazy does tom jones ever
sit in bed with competition go
no yes my life is crazy every night yeah
i love it
that's amazing yeah still it's it's
unbelievable well you know i mean you're
in it
and if you love it as much as you're
telling me you do
you'll be you'll be in it forever yeah
okay
what's the one song that you wish it'd
be newest i would have loved to have
written like
an up tempo kind of hit the road jack
kind of tuned well you could still do it
i just love like that ray charlesy piano
well the regret that i have was um
paul mccartney wrote the long and
winding road for me
no way yeah yeah this is the problem i
had a single coming out on a friday
in those days you know everything's
geared up for that single on friday
yeah and then of course my recording
manager said paul sent this song around
right the longer winding road i said
let's do it yeah and he said well it's
got to be your next single paul said
it's got to be your next single i said
well then let's do it
yeah well then we're going to put a stop
on the one we got and it'll take another
month to go in the studio
and all that well we missed it yeah so
it's a regret because i should have said
stop what we're doing drop everything
let's do that song
yeah and then ray charles did it you see
yeah yeah when i heard him do it i
thought
[ __ ] you know i mean that's that's the
way i would have done it yeah
oh amazing have you ever had something
go wrong during the performance i did
have this one time it was my first ever
like show like i was in a pub in bedford
this lady came in and she just
when i this is truth she came in and got
naked
in front of like well i was like what do
i do do i still
do i sing but she took everything off
and what did what did you do i just
carried her carried on singing and i had
to dance with her
there you go and then she she got
changed again and she loved it but
that's what happened so that was like a
strange thing for me because she didn't
become your wife or anything
no no no okay so what's the most
showbiz thing that you've ever done i
don't know um
i went to a po i went to stella
mccartney's party in l.a
okay and i walked in and it was full of
like
just just a-listers
yeah and it was little old me just going
boy this is crazy but like
dave go had a good conversation with him
yep
such a lovely guy yeah i spoke to paul
mccartney as well but loads of people in
there like
i spoke to christine aguilera which was
pretty crazy katy perry
and i was yeah i was just that was for
me i was like wow i mean i'm in a room
with
showbiz showbiz people yeah yeah it's
great yeah it is
but it makes me it made me think i want
to be
up here with these with them with them
yeah sure yeah yeah well that's a great
way to do it you know great way to look
at it
yeah i want to be in that gang for sure
i want to be part of this
yeah yeah so on your phone speed daily
who's the most famous person you've got
i've got cavanaugh's number
he's pretty famous yeah i understand
yeah i know he is i'm about to have your
number
well of course pretty famous um
kelly jones i got yeah you know kelly's
a good friend of mine but
russell crowe you know in australia yeah
yeah i talked to him
jerry lee lewis little richard when he
was a lion
yeah yeah i used to call little richard
up a lot and what was he like
fantastic just crazy guy oh you but i
knew him you see since the 65.
so we i bumped into him a lot so i used
to call a lot of
elvis presley did you would you bail him
up yeah would you rather sure
wow i tried to get the sad part was when
he was
when he wasn't listening to anybody
towards the end of his life
and the guys the memphis mafia you know
because they knew
that he would listen to me sometimes and
uh so they said could you
call elvis because he's fired us all and
he's
destroying himself and we can't help him
oh sinatra like
sonata was great i mean uh he was the
guy that said
talk about phone numbers you know if you
ever if anybody ever leans on you
yeah you call this number right really
taken care of really really elvis
and the beatles what is the truth behind
did he like the beatles
did he want the beatles to come to
america
[Music]
not really no no no well you see because
the band scene was very big but they did
shake the [ __ ] out of him i do i must
say that
yeah you know they shook him up yeah
whole shook up
yeah so they did shake him up
so now and i asked him about it you know
and he says thank god for you this is
what he said to me
he said because the british group you
know all british groups all the time
british group
you're the only one male singer you know
that that
won yeah and um so anyway so he says to
me
when they split up right in 1970 so he
said
is that right the sp the beetle split up
i said
yeah i said is that in your eyes is that
good or bad
and he said well he said see the thing
that he said i thought we could use them
as a backing man no way hand to god
and he said you know he said you do some
of your songs i do some of my songs
on stage together one end one end and
have the beatles backing us up
wow he said wouldn't that be great i
said you know i don't think they'd go
for it
but what a great idea wasn't it what a
good idea yeah that'd have been amazing
there you go what piece of advice would
you give somebody new
trying to break in to the music industry
uh be yourself 100 yeah
be yourself be yourself and be true to
yourself yeah because you
gotta you gotta look in the mirror and
you gotta see yourself
now you either like yourself or you
don't if you don't like yourself you're
in trouble
yeah because you won't believe yourself
you know you won't believe in yourself
so you have to believe in yourself when
all others i mean it's a rudyard kipling
thing you know if
but when all others around you say
wait a second yeah and you keep punching
until somebody
says we get it yeah if you believe in it
someone will believe in it too there you
go and then that's what starts to fire i
was going to say as well
one thing that what's one thing you
haven't done that you would love to do
in your career yeah um nothing really
just more the same
you know the only thing that's catching
up with me is time an old fellow said to
me once in a paper mill i used to work
in a paper mill
and he said to me i hear you can sing i
said yeah i can say
he said well then why don't you i said
well i've got to hold this job down you
know i was a teenager
for the money and he said well look he
said when you're old like me
he was about 65 or 70 i think at the
time
he said what you've got left are
memories
right make sure that they're good ones
yeah and it's up to you
now to create your own what will be
memories
you know make sure they're good ones so
so that's that's it you got to
you got to do it because we only get one
go around
that's it thank you so much my pleasure
i'm enjoying it honor to meet you and uh
oh yeah i can say now no it's good
friends
well there we go and you know it's great
to hear somebody that can sing
a young person that can sing thank you
and that's you
thank you so much it's the truth thank
you
certain firefighters made calls to their
families because they weren't sure they
were going to make it out of that
situation
for them to then be blamed had that
building been cluttered properly that
fire wouldn't have spread
the way